our connections here in Sweden
with the Maple Leafs are deep
Leaf Legend Hall of Famer captain
and alltime leading scorer Matt
[Applause] Sun game two of this NHL Global
series these are the two most popular NHL
teams in Sweden Detroit for younger
generation that love the Red Wings
with Nick lrom and Company and for the older
gener the maple Lea saor saling and Matt s
Samson ainet Riley lerson neander Jan Kook
and do go make us proud guys have a great
day let's go to work let's go to
work boys here we go big man ready
boys here we go get out there that's
it all four sweds for the two teams
are in the starting lineup and Lucas
Raymond for and right Yar cro Lo to
the KNE Lander for Toronto guys attack
the net attack the net go go go go head
up good play almost I I was going to shoot it
actually thought I had a step loose loose it's
loose no wings going get it they walk in front oh
what a save by S made a good save dude nice hey
hey we're done we're done let it go p p we're not
coming from behind we're not coming from behind
and time expires here after the opening 20 minutes
Char Detroit scoreless after one fly with the puck
here let's get ourselves into the game mode like
you're going to be ahead of me way ahead of me or
I'm going to try to go through the stick nice
plays it in deep Austin Matthews feeds it back
in front Hammer wide by that's up you got to least
go check that for what I was in they'll be looking
at it they'll be looking John Kendrick you got to
look at that they'll be looking right now Sheldon
it's okay if the post had not been dislodged would
that Marner shot have gone in it's close calling
the ice stance there's no goal there is no goal
Matthew by stronga BRS it free with the chance
HS It Up Down the puck still lose they Jam away at
it he want the penalty shot there's a penalty shot
awarded to Detroit as the Toronto player covers
the puck in the goal crease and it's going to be
Daniel spraw has to be somebody who's on the ice
and here he comes top of the circles middle of
the the ice now with a deep and scor let's go go
come on boys let's play in their end let's play in
their end Detroit kind of assuming their dominance
in the second period Lucas Raymond with a
shot and the wings have a two to nothing
lead ready boys here we go guys attack the
net attack the net oh much better face much
better Presence at the net tarus Fe out
back neander gathers it back up what a
move by dander winds in Waits feeds it
back for the score berzi Taps it home
play hey we're good boys we're good let's
get it back go marer looking for tarus Neil
Anders in front of the de and he come on yes
Willie on a tie game here in Stockholm and his
grandmother watching him play for the first
time with a very subdued Swedish celebration
Mitchell great pass oh why where these guys
down here we wear them down the rest of the
way go go go go head up Lea win the face off sent
it around back of the net [Applause] comes what a
play come all the way back and taking the
lead in a game where there was nothing going
on for Toronto for two periods they're now
leading with 5 minutes left ramble draw heads
upy oh the plays it back for cider shoot
that was blocked in front and Riley plays
it out going to be cleared PHS are going to
win it and the horn will signal a dramatic
come from behind win in Stockholm led by the
super SED himself William nander it's a hell
of a job to come back and get those points
fellas talked about overwhelming with their
Pace but to me I know we lose the second
period but we're set up through the game a
Sammy making some big saves for and a huge
power play [Music] [Laughter] [Applause]
goal